Okay, so for anyone who doesn't know what Slack looks like, it's basically like Zoom
chat in effect. It's got lots of features but in effect you can create channels and
in case some of them we might want to use for sending notifications to, some of them
we might not, so I've got 100 pictures of cows which we're not going to use at all.
You see I've set up a Birt Suite Enterprise app and that's how we're basically going to
hook into Slack, we're going to send notifications as that app. So if I, let's see this, why
has it changed?
Just keep swiping.
Keep swiping over. So let me go to, so this is an authentication token which should allow
us to connect to Slack. This is real Slack so it's probably going to go wrong.
Right, so you can now see the channels that I've enabled or selected within Slack are visible,
so I'm able to enable all channels to send notifications from scans. I can also deselect
a couple that I'm not really interested in sending. I can then save that config. Now
when I go to a site, so this is the sites tree and in particular if I go to this first order
site, I can see in the details of that site towards the bottom. So there's currently no Slack
notifications setup. I edit that site and then I go to see the channels that I previously
selected. So I can add a couple of different channels in there and then I can save that.
Right, and now I can go and start a scan. Fingers crossed when we start the scan we should get
a notification to tell us it's starting. It's just waiting for an agent so it might be a minute.
Ta-da! Not that page. So you see now we've got a notification saying the scan has started
and it's told us where it started. And now we've got to wait approximately 22 seconds for the scan
to finish. We've got any mute music? No? Dance? You good? Sorry. No? Should have done a quicker scan. Oh well.
Come on. Ta-da! Right, so now you see the scan's completed. It's got time. And we can also drill down
and see what issues we've found. So we've found a certain number of issues, statistics on how many
requests have made, etc. And you can also click straight through to view the scan results. That link
doesn't work in this demo just because it's a separate workspace. So that's it. And then to actually
remove the integration you're also able to go back to the Slack page and then you just remove Slack.
And then we're back to where we were.